good morning to you good morning Mr Rob
thank you very much for being with us so
I've laid out some of the plans there
just give us in some more detail why
I've decided to toughen these uh
sentencing guidelines well we've
published The Wade review as you
mentioned there are a whole range of
recommendations will report and answer
all of them uh in the summer but I can
tell you three things right now we think
in the case of domestic murders
obviously predominantly men against
women where there's a history of
controlling and coercive Behavior we
think the sentences should be increased
to reflect that slow torment on top of
the severity of the crime we'll
introduce immediately a statutory
aggravating factor that can lift
sentences by anything up to two years or
even more that depends on what a Court
decides and I will also consult on a
starting point of 25 years in those
cases on top of that in relation to
Overkill and the so-called rough sex
defense we're going to also increase the
sentences in the relation to the latter
our right to the sentencing Council
because it's their prerogative and
ultimately in all of this I
uh men who commit these awful crimes to
spend longer Behind Bars and I want
women to feel more confident that the
justice system is on their side and
reflecting the full appalling nature of
the crimes that they suffer yeah and
this has been warmly welcomed by groups
that work with this I'm sure that
they're um happy that you're going
further there is there are other parts
to this as well though I do want to ask
you a little bit about
um something that's in the Domestic
Abuse Act that allows perpetrators to
cross-examine uh Partners in
relationships in courts Charities are
really asking you to ban that practice
is that something you're going to push
forward on I always look at these things
and and for example in relation to rape
we introduced pre-recorded video
evidence
um I think you have to be careful that
you allow the evidence to be tested but
with the extra money we're putting into
victim support I quadrupled it since
2010 and with the other measures that
we're taking we want to try and make the
experience of victims and Witnesses in
court as sensitive as we can a because
we owe them a moral duty of care but
also because we're more likely to secure
convictions that way yeah and just
finally on on this as well and and
slightly related after the murder of
zarolina and the sentences of Jordan
McSweeney last year he didn't come up to
court to to hear the final judgment and
you said at the time that you might
Force judges to bring these people up if
that's something you're going to push
forward just definitely something I'm
looking at I think both as a matter of
uh respect and recognition of the
bereaved of victims but also frankly
respect for the principle of British
Justice I think we should look at making
an aggravating factor in sentencing if
an individual committed one of these
heinous crimes just snubs the court okay
and Mr Robot I've got you here you will
have seen the reporting from our
political editor yesterday and Beth
Rigby about allegations that you're
facing about your conduct with some of
your colleagues are you've been accused
of being a bully how do you answer those
allegations this morning well as you
know from previous questions that's been
put to me I've said that I would
cooperate fully with the inquiry I'm not
going to comment on Anonymous sources in
the media in fact it's a breach of the
rules of the inquiry for anyone to do so
and of course I want to respect that I
want to just show you what's been said I
know you said they're Anonymous sources
we have voice them up these are people
that Beth has spoken to and here is one
of the allegations there he created an
awful atmosphere it was coercive
Behavior he had people in tears after
coming out of his office but they
wouldn't complain do you recognize that
well as I just said to you and you know
I'm going to say this it's actually
improper for me to comment on the
question you've just asked it's a breach
of the rules of the inquiry anyone
involved in the inquiry who is
commenting to the media anonymously or
otherwise is breaching the rules and as
a matter of basic professional Integrity
I'm not going to do that fine so it's a
professional Integrity do you think it's
important that the people you work with
like working with you look of course you
want to have a positive relationship
with the vast majority of people that I
do that's the case but I'm not going to
comment on the allegations or the claims
as I said to you before and I've said on
I've answered questions on Sky News
before it's actually improper for anyone
who's involved in the inquiry to comment
on it uh with the media and I appreciate
it but I'm talking about that I'm not
sure you quite do you want to ask your
questions
more philosophically because you know we
all work in in organizations and
sometimes you work with people you don't
quite get on with I'm saying do you
think you should always be you know
friendly with those that you work with
or because there's space there to you
know not to get on look what I'd say is
um a professional relationship
particularly between politicians and
civil servants what you want to do is be
bigger than some of your parts there's a
really important piece around candid
advice a full advice from civil servants
and ultimately when ministers decide and
offer ministerial challenge that's
important too you want to try and get
the uh the best of both of those
elements just very high standards for
the people that work with absolutely the
highest of standards and that could be
difficult to me sometimes would you say
look I think if you're in any Walk of
Life in the media in sport in uh CEO of
a big business let alone in government
uh you want to set high standards
because that's where you deliver and
look if you if you think about the stuff
we're talking about today delivering for
the victims of these appalling crimes I
think it's right just to remember that
we all serve the British public and in
my case dealing with the MOJ I'm serving
victims and bereaved as some of those
appalling crimes of course I'm going to
do everything I can to drive the reforms
that we've been able to announce today
and in other areas as well and Lasting
on this you said Sophie a little while
ago that you'd resign if you were found
guilty of it is that still the case I
haven't changed the view I've taken on
it but I'm not commenting further okay I
want to bring you on to the review Into
The Met
um yes it's reported this morning
there's going to be some really
concerning critical reporting coming out
about the Met next week I mean
that Force has already got to get his
houses automatically so they're going to
expect weekly uh Revelations about it
what's to be done about that well if I'm
going to get ahead of the Casey report
but look we want uh a no hold bars uh
review we want to uh look at this as
critically as we possibly can I know
commissioner Rowley who I know well he
was Chief Constable of sorry police
before becoming a met commissioner is
already conducting a range of checks for
example on vetting and existing checks
so we will we will Embrace and engage
with any of those findings because we
want to get this right we want to be
proud of our police forces I think the
vast majority of police officers do an
incredible job but clearly these uh
terrible things that happened in the
past must be addressed and people must
be able to have confidence you know I've
been talking about the sentencing for
murder and domestic abuse cases against
women well it's the same with policing
we want uh women across this country to
know that the law enforcement Authority
is right across the border on their side
working for them and they're protecting
them not posing a threat to them
appreciate your time this one I've got a
couple more questions for your strikes
now if we can it seems as if they're
finally getting somewhere with the
strikes there's a deal on the table
um why did it take so long
at this point where we're on the cusp of
hopefully getting a settlement I don't
think it is much uh value in just finger
pointing but what I would say is I think
that the health sector's done a great
job and it's good that the vast majority
of the NHS unions have backed the latest
settlement we of course would hope that
the BMA would follow suit in relation to
Junior doctors but the critical thing is
the fairness uh that we of course want
for nurses doctors and other medical
staff without uh without creating the
extra pressure on inflation we've just
seen from the obr this week with the
budget suspension coming down yeah we've
got to make sure we get the right
balance between those two where's the
extra money coming from them
well we will have to come from within
the uh the budgets that uh So within
existing budget it's not coming from
outside well that'll be for the health
secretary to uh to set out the details
of but we announced the budget uh the
the chance to announce the budget this
week I think he's uh it was an excellent
budget for business you can see that our
plan is working inflation scheduled now
to come down to 2.9 from the peak of 11
the economy growing this year for the
fears of recession of a beta in terms of
what the obr is predicting and I think a
really good package for business 25
billion pounds of tax cuts but also
things like extending the child
allowance for months of uh nine month
old to four-year-old sooner for my baby
who's two we've got you've you and many
others particularly on Lower incomes may
I say squarely in our Focus excellent
stuff uh Deputy Prime Minister and
justice secret dominant Rob thank you
very much for your time good to talk to
you good to have you with us thank you